I started in this business when I was 19
years old when I killed somebody boom
boom boom
I used the hollow head jimmy hoppa was
one of my best customers
everytime he had a headache I would say
aspirin obviously we hear different
stories
I didn't hear stories you heard Phil
Leonetti yes he makes up stories
salvie testa was the pure us young
killer but everybody says that
Leonetti also believes salvie testa was
a great guy he let himself oniy he
wanted to kill him
how much time did you spend with Nicky
Scarfo I hated him he was evil you said
that to Angelo Bruno are you gonna kill
Nicky I'm not gonna repeat that
why should I repeat you didn't hear me
so you had nothing to do with the
quaaludes indical Kenneth they set me up
guess who went to jail what did you
learn from skinny razor
he taught me number one don't trust
nobody I know it that man how did those
conversations take place between you and
Morley no loneliness nothing he knows
love either Gumbo's main in the world
spit on the ground what Apple with Sonny
Liston what still what's this - you
don't even know then I gotta help you
that's it that's why I have you here
how'd you become a boss - because that's
where the controversy comes in what's
your controversy me and Killa brutal and
Carlo Gambino nobody could touch me
[Music]
run homie look what I become
my guest today it's got a different kind
of a story his story goes all the way
back to him being friends with Jimmy
Hoffa and on top of that he also had a
relationship with the man who killed
Jimmy Hoffa obviously it was involved in
a mob world in Philadelphia crime family
and working with Angelo Bruno had a
chance to do some work with Carlo
Gambino pretty deep stories here and on
top of that he ends up in the mid 90s
with joy Molina when they get out of a
jail together he ends up becoming the
active boss of the Philadelphia crime
family for four years until eventually
becoming a witness and he became the
highest ranking member that old mafia
family to become a witness and go go
work with the FBI so having said that my
guest today Rafa natality Ralph thank
you so much for being a guest today on
that attainment my pleasure
appreciate you for coming out you just
says four questions that I'll give you
the best answers for and truthful first
question why are you doing this what why
you want to tell this story why yeah why
not well why wouldn't I say everybody
knows who I am more like it was I
started in this business when I was 19
years old really heavy I know every man
every boss and I worked for the men who
were controlled by these men the
culinary workers and the Teamsters Jimmy
Hoppa was one of my best customers
every time he discussed every time he
had a headache I would see aspirin as
simple is that we got along I became
very friendly with Jimmy I'm the last
man that he came to see when he was
trying to get me Union back by acclaim
when he came into the South Jersey
called a friend of his and the Teamsters
said would you call that little guy tell
him I want to see him
I met the rickshaw I liked to talk them
I know what it was
okay he could be called me and I went I
went there
and were to friends are with me I make
them sit outside of me because I didn't
trust nobody in those days and I was
good friends with Jimmy so they said in
the lobby money search me and Mike my
room they're both gone them hundreds of
different and I went into same mice ones
talking with John Greeley
they were sitting through on ovary hugs
we always hugged really because we
became friends besides me doing and
taking away his headaches once once or
one when somebody wanted the pill there
Teamster local out of his international
and he was getting and making speeches
and whatever he called for me he sent
word to the guy from whoever they were
what do you mean by you what he asked me
to his headaches because he won't let me
let me explain I went to see that the
certain gentleman who worked and I
talked that he said now we're pulling
out this and that there I said do you
know what you this is my do you know but
you're doing for yourself - doing the
Jimmy and the rest of the things yes I
do and you say no you're you're still
gonna try to port you're gonna make a
mistake and that's all I said
I'll see and within months nobody could
find that guy he just disappeared then
they found him somewhere laying down
with two three holes in his head and
that that local stood in the
International that's how he built the
International and they loved him because
he treated him well but some men marigo
explodes their sense of propriety and at
that time we became friends and he never
called no one else when he had a
headache that's why he came to see me in
the rickshaw
one to sit down I said another strange
something talking the corner was a by
the bar it was if the lunch was quiet he
said well I want to take over the local
again the Union the International by
acclaim he was Jimmy was a strong guy I
said Jimmy why are you doing this you
got all the money in the world I know
you have it you you got a great pension
you got a great family Josie was
sleeping upstairs his way but what's
were you he said out this the only thing
I know how to do I said to myself he
wasn't a moving I'm a womanizer I like
most most men he wasn't no no that he
wasn't a drunk and he was in a gambler
he's the things that men do when they
have money and time he didn't do any
looser line I'm telling because I know I
said just go back and enjoy your life
Jimmy you did everything you had to do I
love everybody loves rap I'm going to do
something please
I know the state of Jersey and all the
Teamsters they love you and they fear
you
please get them but when I go into the
convention the back me I said Jimmy I'm
gonna give you one answer first of all a
man can serve two kings you know where I
was what I was almost born into he says
yes I do I said well I'm gonna have to
go and see him and if that name washes
his hands of you I'll help you cuz I
didn't like the punks that were pulling
out for him they promise to loose I
promised him that they gave him nothing
but they gave him freedom and they Hayes
had his pension he had everything he I
said okay I'll give you a call and I'll
let you know please well I'm gonna find
out shortly shook his head I've seen my
two friends okay somebody everything's
okay I went to see Angelo Bruno at his
home a sample little bit when he was
killed right in front of there but
that's another story when in his white
answered or sua Noctem was quietly Oh
Rob what are you doing it I said when
the King calls his people have to come
save me Rob come on in he said I know
where you got I know that other guy came
into the city
look at him like the FBI to us and what
do you want now I said he asked me to
help them to be teamster boss again he
said well I ain't gonna happen
everything's been done agreements paid
everything's done tell him to go home
and enjoy his life I said I told him
that already but he wants me to come and
help
note don't go near him don't go by him
after you you told him already well he
don't have to be told again send him a
morning with someone else
you stay away from them I said but just
stay away from them
I'm telling you what's wrong answer I
would did everything for you for
everybody because that's how I was
wouldn't because I was Angeles last
moment of everything he said the man
upstate Jersey you know I mean the man
that you went one day and you see was up
on the roof with the pigeons flying
pigeons
oh you you want me to go see him no
they're gonna do it and they'll take
care of this business my god I said is
that your less he said that's my laser
okay good I'll see you later
I love you I kiss him on the cheek and
boom I left I know he was going to be
dead was in or missing I didn't know it
severed in two or three weeks and he was
in two or three weeks yeah because he
called this guy's I got it he was so he
made an agreement with some men that he
used to deal with in a Mafia family from
New York and when he makes this
agreement they were supposed to be
binding on either one he space it will
send somebody saying talk to you you
know they send somebody they send three
people the envy and Gretel brothers and
Pedrito as I say my president Branson is
saying the Sweetman went to see him and
he was never so again it's never no fine
no nothing and that was the end of Jimmy
Hoffa because he didn't want to live
nice for this family anyone to go out
and still have that hair I am in
Philadelphia ever Shawn I think is like
the broadcaster at Fox News asked to see
me I went up to see him
I said yeah what's up he said take him
talking about everything he said to a
friend
of yours who's the friend said Frank
Sheeran thanks you yes what what is what
did he want from you
he told me he shot and killed Jimmy
Hoffa what in fact it's only I saw it
filmed I said not in a million years as
you have to get near him no but he told
me I'm believing I totally up your odds
are gonna get together I'm going to
investigate you do it because you've
always been nice with people in you do
what you got to do
he's a liar he wants to be somebody
before he dies because he's sick I think
she's got cancer you're saying that yeah
hey show mama okay good lo and behold he
investigated where they found the blood
on the floor
then when the FBI sent for you
forensic people in they tested it it
wasn't Jimmy Hoffa's blood
he said he shot him twice in him and
then I'm when I went up to see my went
up to see Eric again I said what did I
tell you he wouldn't talk to him what's
wrong with you
he said my monster he he's a liar and I
said well I told you that for you you
won the bid puted he says I'm sorry I
shall listen to you listen Jimmy Hoffa
story and they'll never find him unless
it said somebody one of those three now
Tommy hey Ben
burr Julie old the shooter suceed gotten
a quarter each other and the two ins
Reddy brothers but for Julio's not
around because he got killed a couple of
months after that because he was walking
around in New York City and I killed
that cop guy I should be getting the top
I should be made a captain I should be
this and that he was a main man went
with the Union because I heard he was
doing it he's putting this spotlight on
him he was killed within that week and I
heard that he came out of a restaurant a
little bit resection boom boom boom he
was done no more talking they lengthy
and ready brothers one stood in New York
and one hundred times ago he was labeled
ooh
Osen and they were doing things and
making money illegally but not too much
they skirted when I got into Lewisburg a
year later so so I don't like them base
who's there Tommy ain't ready he said
but that was a mr. block and it was a B
C D block
I said she should tell me yeah your
mommy hug me listen cuz he knew what I
was and he knew what I would do
everybody Lou I said good huh how's
everything you know things were getting
too hot around their eggs they pick me
up on some day gave me ten years and
listened that and I looked at him I said
my god look at this look what happened
to Jimmy and he was part of it and when
I went to Eric I talked to him after
that he said I'm so glad you told me
that I was making a fool of myself well
I never Sherman I just told you he did
not do it he's a liar so that's that
story but Jimmy Hoppa did you ever meet
Frank like did you know who my new
friend knows since he used to come in to
the bar that and I'm gonna bring you
another name up you skinny racer did you
ever hear that horse yeah all right have
fun mentor from the guy said what's that
he's the boss's mentor he was he was a
guy that his mind mentoring was yours he
was scarfo's he was described scoffs no
he hated scars oh please don't
and I know you were told dish that
people you had in here are making a
story up that's why you Leonetti makes
up stories
Oh Phil Leonetti yes he makes up stuff
yes he's not to kill he's supposed to be
Phil Leonetti makes up stories
yes I mean it's been I wouldn't say that
you would have known that skinny razor
was known as a guy that skinny razor was
the most feared men in the United States
but then he wouldn't talk to them people
went talk to fool inland to you or Nicky
Scarfo
he became when he got 45 years he became
a witness the only time I'd be paying it
became a witness
was at the end when I took intro money
I'm being right they made a Morse where
you gotta take care of my family cuz I'm
gonna stay they needed help in the city
they were trying I was someone to put
that group together nobody else I said
but you got to promise me one thing on
our blood something happens to me was I
get killed
I go to jail you go and bring your
envelope every Monday I mean every month
excuse me and bring it over to my wife
yeah good you know what happened mmm not
a time not a dime that's what they are
that's why I'm here a little bit what's
Joe we got to do a leonetti and scar for
though Joe we should go Bashar was they
were together as brothers one time
ladies not Scarfo is a sick man he was
born sick he's gonna dissect and
Leonetti he wanted leonetti's Ribisi you
were gonna you got the story first and
you believed it he wanted leonetti to be
honored and wrote about in the paper
like other people that's what he wanted
he wanted under to be like he wanted him
to be like salvie testa salvie testa was
the purest young killer but everybody
says that so so what you say know what
you're saying right there is to
challenge you a little bit but why would
you challenge me oh no no - challenge
you on that a little bit Leonetti also
believes salvie testa was a great guy
well because she's telling you you're
listening to him when you're saying the
same thing no I'm not
I said sally was ly lady cell phonee
no no Leonetti said sally is also great
guy Oh Diane you believe that he he
wanted to kill him he was told to kill
him when he had a chance because he
reported the Scarfo Nicky Scarfo hated
almond kids from downtown course
everyone knows that mom or do you say
everyone that you're telling me
something
no no everyone knows that knowing that
he listened we went when sorry okay you
tell me when skarphol passed away three
years ago not a lot of people showed up
to his funeral you know known that there
was not a lot of you know he was hated
he hated me yeah he would curse Scott
because I a strange a little Brunel many
years before that I'm gonna go kill
Mickey's gonna cause us problems with
Atlantic City you said that sounds a
little boring are they gonna call kill
Nikki I'm not gonna repeat that why
should I repeat you didn't hear me I
said it and nobody said to me thank you
dear he's as his uncle's came over than
when the boat would me the war that we
had with the Americanized Isis because
when they came off the boat they call
them zips and they start tape by tonight
there's two numbers than their
everything every little gambling house
that's what happened Nicky Scarfo was
scum he did everything wrong you see
what he did how he conducted him he
didn't he hated him he had his salary
tested he hated Nicky when his father
became boss he hated it but he he did
what he had to do Nicky Scarfo I
wouldn't I'm gonna treat him I turn my
back that's what he was he wouldn't you
wouldn't what I couldn't hear you I
wouldn't treat him if I turned my back
on him well and did you see what lien
lady told you when he went and gave what
I mean that's the morning testimony he
said that and my uncle told me to build
this just the wall behind his kitchen
and then the yard and then there was an
alleyway he wanted me to building before
a wall ain't 4/12 be cinder blocks why
do you want me to build this wall said
he said because Ralphie his hands they
killed me and Ames turned him down but
he ain't gonna listen to him because
he'll come up and kill me if if he and
it's easy and let's proof he said it
you're you're
man that told you they said they letting
never been nothing he said he'd kill
twenty would he kid in his brain and he
listened you listen don't fine it's up
to you
nobody's like me nobody I'm and I'm not
telling you to believe it I killed more
people than cancer for Angelo Bruno for
Joe batters in Chicago for the heads of
the Teamsters haters a call me whenever
they needed me I was there
everybody in Chicago belongs to Joe
batters I was in prison already in
Lewisburg I had a vision in Lewis break
from my wife and some other girlfriends
those whose husbands were in there they
drove up from South Jersey two cops that
were watching us listen said well when
you're done go see Victor Kathleen Wynn
Cecile I said for what autism he said
he's got some people man some people I
went down I walked in but Katherine is
six seven suits FBI I looked at them he
said he's a gentleman from the FBI they
want to speak to you and I think you
should listen to it I said okay I said
no what do you fellas one said we were
told to offer you complete freedom I
just started that the 27-year sentence
the three years I had no mustering it so
much will give you a certain amount of
money to live
you have no nobody body no law or no
message we want the information on
Angelo Bruno on Tony Accardo okay listen
you got the wrong guy
but you you just starting you gonna have
to do this you got the wrong man
I walked out and I went there and that's
what I said to them you see some thumb I
never told anybody I kills anybody when
doing it Tommy Lillian and Leonetti
leading lady sees me and run as long as
I am here run down the street and that's
the story about them so you you will get
ready to tell a story about the skinny
razor John pick any razor was your
mentor was the most feared man in the
United States what made him feel he was
19 years old
Al Capone was they were having that war
between the Irish sending it and Al
Capone and his men and whatever he came
to Philadelphia and made it make they
made arrangements other detective see
search him find a gun on him and they've
given him one year he wanted to get away
for you too many guys were getting
killed back and forth he was with Al
Silverberg how Silverberg once started
with murder incorporated was proficient
at killing our Silverberg Al Capone and
his lawyer they were talking he said
that's just the young man you told me
about skinny told me skinny told me this
word-for-word some I was so poor my my
pants was thing from Washington for
doing this I was freezing that day and
he said I'm Al Capone I said yes mr.
Silber burka he said it's a piece of
paper they he told me what he thinks of
you but you will do anything to better
yourself yes I would
isn't it miss ain't names on you I'm
gonna go away for a year and when I come
home I don't want to see or hear or have
any evidence that they were ever alive
I'm leaving it up to you and this man
told told me how summer break stood for
you
how subtle Berg was some some guy before
he went away got caught in a murder and
sent in the central part of the country
when another man Jeff Newman they were
with the two mom he took the paper
everything for months they said he said
I will tell you you will be sent word
way to go when you go and you'll live
somewhere right outside in the suburbs
they'll give you a little car and if you
are without Silverberg section walk
you're gonna be made the rest of your
life and that's what happened
and he told ang well after that when he
came over from Chicago he said and I'm
gonna go see my friend down in Florida
he had a kite at home nice logs a little
bit but a nice little one this is what I
told Ralphie if aunt needs anything
he'll call you I told him you're the
only one he can trust in this city and I
know where you could because I went with
him when a couple things he loved you
know what you're doing
he wants to check out he cleaned him
right up cleans everybody the war
stopped stopped you want to talk about
go away stallion Eddie and Nicky Scarfo
and all them crumbs they know nothing
they was told nothing and they know
nothing but I seen it comes from my mom
I seen I heard and I know what and I was
there on a couple of things with him he
took me he saw something in me and I
thanked him and we were friends when I
hear for my life and he stood for me and
now Silverberg and he came in with an
old girlfriend his piercing blue eyes
took my Rafi I heard a lot about you I
said I'll ER I heard volumes about you
mr. Silverberg no no al because skinny
loves you I said I love him
so take care of him I said I will
devastate their true stories just things
that happened and everybody knows it
very convincing your method of
storytelling is very cannot a story man
I can't tell a lie when I was a little
boy I found that Liars of nothing and
you always have a problem these guys I'm
gonna be this Leonetti was in Lewisburg
I was in Lewisburg at the time and they
were all down there the prisoners
waiting they get the sentence then they
brought him back to the city he got 45
years or 40 years he's [ __ ] his
pants excuse me
mine went and they become a witness
immediately immediately you tell me
they might please you you might be
pleased within an item if I don't please
you your hunt excuse my language in the
way edge but I'm telling you the truth I
can do anything I want when you're
telling the truth
when you tell them a lie you'll find out
what what else did you learn from skinny
razor what were some of the things he
taught you when he was mentoring you
he taught me number one don't trust
nobody I know it that man he didn't mean
everything he meant nobody it would be
if you talk to him your life would be
different your life not to be a criminal
message them we know that but your life
would be different because you meet a
man's man what he did in his life times
unreal unreal every boss in the country
pays honor to him money-wise and was
with respect
Nicky Scarfo lien ladies if they never
come near his saloon because they were
afraid why nobody was going they were
afraid even when he was a made man Nicky
he's the worst the worst and I would
have said if they didn't build that
thing I but then I went to jail after
that I've been in jail a lot of years me
let me just say he he I'm gonna even say
shouldn't his pants when he already
gotten through that sentence when they
had me in Florida before the judge
didn't send someone something else
the prosecutors a friend to sentence me
on the dangerous spatial special vendor
check all this stuff you could get 25
years on a single count of any counts
that you have in your oh my god I saw
these [ __ ] what they did they
want to take me away from my family but
I took myself away I believed myself
nobody but all of a sudden fun they
called me forget what they said things I
never remember was I
I was here I did what are you talking
about
and Jake Osman was angel Bruno's best
friend to find fine men they robbed my
men around like you the people work for
you who would never do anything like
that but I was born into it I'm still a
nice man but I'm still me anybody comes
near my family or what I'm going to go
kill her
nobody comes near my family thank god
you're gonna compare Nicky Scarfo that
crumb that he is with me
well Julian let he was he's [ __ ]
this painting into a day well how
vicious were you like I was good well
I'm gonna when I killed somebody for
somebody boat is good good reason I'm
not trying to go on kill it
innocent people but when I did it I
didn't like skinny little I shot two
three times right in the face if I could
have Mallory in the back of the head but
in the face they die without a pain I
made a joke of it I never hurt anybody
boom boom boom I used to hollow hairs
you know wonder how hollow heads are
that's all I use and then the Lord know
I did it
that's about me that's right quim prove
it well I had to plead to six murders on
my last one so they let me please listen
that there and I went home to my wife
and family they visited me every day met
every day but every time of visiting no
matter where I was in Lewisburg and in a
land of federal prison I would say of
all the high ones and they loved me
every time I walked in I was welcome
seeing seeing fully in any ever walked
in in a prison and got welcomed like I
did you could write a scrip for that all
this I could give you a script about
salvie testa that create so vengeance
did you know that for the people that
kills his father Phil no no no
salvie testa killed the people today
kills his father okay you know yeah well
sally was savvy was loved by everybody
don't you had to love him you know why
he was not a guy to pick on anybody that
was weaker he wasn't he wasn't a liar
the last time I saw him before and I
want to went to prison then it almost
robbed me it's Sally
he lives up the street one chunk Street
and on the corner lived he answered
Bruno's daughter and son-in-law he said
my father wants to send me to Temple
University all this is in I don't want
to go to no university I can't be I'm
gonna be me I looked at it a minute yeah
17 18 years old I said Sally he's
looking at me I know that and his mother
had cancer at the time he was gonna die
he said I came through it the priest my
father that way I love my mom but I'm
not gonna go no universe I'm gonna be
what he was and what he's doing and what
I'm gonna do so can she kissed me
I never saw me because I'm run away to
prison when he wrote the story on
vengeance he was a man Mickey one of it
Leonetti to be sort of like he couldn't
carry his toothbrush and mr. truth I
don't think fill one of the life though
what I don't think Phil wanted the life
well wait a minute wait a minute but say
what you said it's true
nobody screw me he but he did it because
he was afraid of his uncle sure tell us
something
summers tell you my uncle kill me then
if you're a man would you let your uncle
you're the father so you gotta go do
this you go and you go do it
you don't want to do it then you're
you're lying to yourself how much
somebody just done with Nicky Scarfo me
yeah not too much
when we grew up and I hated him because
you wish it yeah
Hey
was evil I think what how old were you
when you met him first you and me well
he was I was going to junior high school
and he used saengil in the corner there
that's why not you know we knew when I'm
anxious but I don't I saw I saw in his
eyes that he he wasn't true he wanted to
kill people but to be a killer
it wasn't a killer he was a savage
what's the difference the killers have
killer sense his job that's the
difference I had a job that was my job
what's this I didn't know I didn't know
the difference between that if I did I'd
be a doctor today I'll be taking care of
you when you come in you once said you
wanted to kill your death how was your
let me let me explain that where we live
in South Philly was on Morton Street and
on tenth Morton was a civil war cemetery
right opposite of George Washington
School those was a Civil War Cemetery
well they decided to take that up and
make it a playground for everybody I
hope for square box city box we used to
go as boys 11 12 years old jump and
playing we were doing them one night and
I forgot it was late it was like 9:30
quarter-cent my father said you better
get in at 9 o'clock so I come in the
door was fought who's there behind the
door my father and he did time in the
Eastern sleep end for attempted murder
long time ago you son of a [ __ ] I told
you coming at certain time I'm looking
at missing I didn't go to work just
hustled numbers took bets to cover it
and he's looking that's how face my mind
went and I walked in on the boy and son
of a [ __ ] like and he got his foot when
you want to kick someone your location
but if you want to kick him you kick
them on the side
that means your number to trim I'm
taking you in
well he kicked me a shot knocked me
forward stop it
entry war I turned around and I told him
don't you ever ever touch me again cause
I'll kill you he knew I would I didn't
know I would but look what I said that's
how I started
I took my I gave him I gave my soul to
the devil how old were you well when I
knew when I would become i i i knew it I
couldn't help it and yet I'm nice what
my family my wife my children other
people's children I'm nice with men like
you and workers and I am I never never
never imposed my will upon another man
unless that man is bad that's my life
did your relationship end up being good
with your dad or Nell with your father
no I never never was good my mother
thought it wasn't too hot either
she hated me sometimes smack me she said
you got to do the dishes today I do
dishes I hope that let me ask the
question you know I'm big on looking at
eyes okay and I think you'll read a lot
of people through when you look at the
rice you're like me yeah when you look
at someone's eyes it tells a story when
I look at your eyes I see oh oh that
there's rage you can tap into a rage
side you just talked about your mom and
dad you talk about the fact that your
mom would say go wash your dishes and
then she my mother was not a real mother
right and then your father is well the
fact that you had the experience would
you say your rage came from your parents
could it could be they were terrible to
me I ride was raised from and we hadn't
we ended she had another boy my have a
brother younger brother but he's not me
he and I loved him I showed him how to
hit a baseball how to do to me he's five
years younger than me and he became
something else so I let him alone he
left
you know I called him a couple of times
you've never returned my call your
brother yeah interesting I can't I can't
overcome that so you've met a lot of
different people because you come from
you know a couple different generations
who would who were some of the folks you
met when you were coming up some of the
big names you met Capone did you meet
some of those names they were the big
names to me but this you mean Frank
Sinatra Frank Sinatra of course I
imagine I met him when he was appearing
I'm glad you asked about it at the black
casino in South Jersey he had to go and
see
say hello to Angelo Bruno because the
poor gnome wasn't going in there to see
him because he didn't like nightclubs
and things and drinking it all so the
chief calls me up I called the chief
what's up he said you got to pick up
Frank Sinatra thanks so much because you
know I didn't like him anyway because
Frank Sinatra is a bully
okay that's a Latin yeah pick him up and
this and that I said okay good
and he was cocky he thought I was just
picked up guys oh yeah yeah okay kid
yeah what are you doing okay you want to
sit in the front mr. Sinatra I said
where you want to sit in the back no I
sit in a problem with you man
anyway I drove him over oh yeah well
maybe say but coming out they heard he
was coming it was it yeah he's the maybe
the greatest pop singer I know what I'll
ever lived but he stinks as a man and he
always did he went in and I said sue
said come on no no I'm gonna sit outside
get some man I see some people I know
I'm gonna say something okay
oh it's been hours just wish what would
come out in stress the door everybody
waited and got with counseling some nice
man pretty cool I said you want to sit
in the front no I said no problem yeah
all of us have seen his manner changed I
didn't know you were you
have to know anything about me I'm just
nice to you because of Angelo Bruno and
he's nice for me because he likes me and
that was all I was saved all the way
back no no Frank Sinatra no this oh
that's better people
they didn't matter to me and the most
important person after many years is my
wife what was your involvement in
Atlantic City an Atlantic City was a
dirty dish town it had nothing after
there was a people was almost starving
they weren't working than when learning
when I went usually I Drive Ange to New
York he goes to social clubs I wanna go
downstairs imma go here there that's all
go see man he comes back he said then
come on when we're going for a ride I
know where nothing okay he was a heavy
smoker you know and I take him because
if he says fansign you don't think I'm
in the club hey say hello to the guy cuz
they won't new me it's been so long who
knows and I put Chetan half-hour so he
comes that come on we're gonna go take a
ride to a hotel Hotel where he said I
know where it's at I'll show you me be
me which Mike guess what's the hotel the
wolves off with stormy we went to the
elevator went up a couple hours past two
or three hours and the elevator door
open who comes out and who's walking
behind him
Carlo Gambino boss is above all bosses I
feel my god they must have some speech
up there was it they had a sweet since
Luciano on it they going to have
meetings up there at that time and
worked over and I see Carla's looking
straight at me legislation I stay still
it's a bad manners to approach a boy
especially one like him too fast
never never step ahead for men too fast
whether he's a boss always dangerous
I just stood there she walked away might
come out look over put his Hannah I'm
not never put your handouts to a boss
who are you were to go shake him
I just he put his head out I better
shake his hand cuz I'm gonna have a hand
let that's the young man I keep telling
you on that oh yes he's told me about
you that you will or capable man capable
means one thing in that language you're
able to do with you I try to be I said
okay
he said we got we came up with an idea
and walk out with us we want to tell you
about it my god girls listen
they made me feel like cowboys don't
reach he said we're talking about
Atlantic City aints told me that you
took over local 170 and canden saying a
problem you took it over you
you had an election you won yeah yes I
did but I give him a giving my time he
said my son's came back cited their
lawyers go to wall speech they play they
know this business they're trying to
raise money for Atlantic City to make it
into a casino town oh my god look at the
who's behind it and he said we have to
send one guy to go see our friends and
it says name my friend in Chicago if we
want you if it works you run that Union
well I got it no but you run that you
run that you and they got another Union
down there you're gonna we're gonna get
that Union your unions to come together
and we're gonna make you run the whole
thing because we want a casino down my
god and that's hell I met Carlo Gambino
and then everything starts a boom get
this one then they start pushing it when
they had when it came up for election a
referendum the pace
they lost not much more but they lost
now when prior to that I went to them
says you know they need some money the
people that are trying to put this for
the paper for everything
oh yeah yeah we're gonna give so much
that's good I can count on you they gave
this one was this was needed imagine
people owning property or beat up hotels
you could sell make another hotel they
didn't give me nothing I said call a
meeting next week I'm gonna meet
everybody and call the bullying trades
to come in tell them roughly said I just
say rob them in town I didn't have to I
was known as frumpy well next week they
what we did and I came in
hey brother let's not talk I'm just
another friendly talk we're going to try
to push that again the next boat and I'm
gonna tell you how much everyone is I'm
gonna have to put in they put big money
up and we got extra money from
Philadelphia because I went up there and
John McCallum was alive at the time you
don't know John McCullough he was a
marine here on the Second World War and
Nicky Scarfo had him killed because of
Atlantic City he went and told I said
John and John wasn't afraid of anybody I
said John we need more money from you he
runs a bullet race plumbers think
they're all making big money this is
what we need and lo and behold they put
up a bundle up for Linux city because
they were transferring guys and get them
jobs and everything and this is the the
reason that Nicky Scarfo hated John
McCullough
that's another reason and Nicky Scarfo
talks they stoled with it don't touch
them stove is it you know still building
what it means okay you talk to him talk
to me he says we gotta kill him because
he's gonna get us in trouble again they
gave money for this and that's still
testing know anything about business he
said I don't let me go I'll take him
you're got nothing to do with it he did
it
he called Long John who was angel
Bruno's legitimate so-called legitimate
partner in the bending cigarette
survives and told him we're going to
have to kill this guy
well they put it together they go there
on a Christmas week John already went
home
he's on the phone talking and the guy
with the bundle of flowers at all
oh yeah mrs. my caller cheap yeah can I
bring this in uh - yeah okay good just
gotta bring see I was puts him down
boom boom boom boom
kills John McCullough while he's talking
on the phone in front of his wife and
then leaves he this kid this junkie he's
don't like this junkie was told by John
and by Long John who was involved with
the whole thing was insane she'll burn
us partner mention and told him don't
worry we're going to fix everything up
you're gonna be a high man in the local
killer and that's how John McCauley got
killed under the orders from mere Mickey
Scarfo telling Long John and he got this
kid to go in and kill you want me to
like him
Long John was a crumb fish like Nicky
Scott he was deathly afraid of Nicky
what was the relation was the Carlo
Gambino ask you to do something with
John Gotti what happened with you and
God II there was something happened with
you and John Gotti John Gotti I never I
never like I'll tell you what he did
what he did he was in Lewisburg with
Roma Grill they were both ones doing a
little bit they saw the talk both more
brackets John mcgrill expire it stopped
guy this night John McGrath told him I
got a language city it's the truth
this is mine I'll give whatever I once I
run the Union they shouldn't you run the
Union we stood Ralphie
now I do it i oh yeah he did it he said
that yeah [ __ ] Ralphie
oh he said thanks yeah okay now John
McBroom became and John Gotti
but he told them I got I'm gonna bet my
Union he went home went to New York City
and then the other crowd she was the his
friend he told him I'm going to get this
this kid says I was crying come he's
going to give it and do anything we want
and if he doesn't well do what we have
to do okay
he's already got a language city John
Gotti I said to my SIA
I said he's got silicon yeah I said how
can I gotta kill this guy he's one aback
with every tale and he's making their
brilliant good thing that's going to
happen but it wasn't what happened
because I still was outside because I
was waiting for mr. mcgrill to come home
and that's how that's what I said about
I don't care about John Gotti John Gotti
says get this hair fix would have put a
barber every day John Conte killed
they'd be DB was the poor number but
pornographer King he was having trouble
in Philadelphia because he put two
places there and the his partners was
Angelo Bruno call the Gambino they
shared everything and it was him
leasing guy say that he had his own
studio it's like you got everything I
said my god everything's coming leaking
over here what's this guy now John Gotti
keeps he bets he couldn't win if he knew
who was gonna win and they banned any
bet anything he was up to here with that
ego to him he gave him so much paid off
but he got to be one day he said
twenty-five thirty thousand on a weekend
I can't afford that
you don't making money you name it well
I'm not making that kind of money and
turned him down for that one time after
that he killed him John Gotti killed
demons real kills him but no reason a
good guy that paid his debts off John
Gotti let's get back to Lane City we
went to three bosses
I only answer to three bosses Angelo
Bruno call the Gambino and Joe baddest
they were and they told me you do what
you have to do they keep that because
that's going to be our city and was a
wide-open order and I did and we made it
and when as soon as they gave him the
they vote we won guess who went to jail
I went to jail they have anyone Charlie
Alan this guy they the insurance time we
had an insurance guy Sean sky gave up I
helped the Jewish guy burn his furniture
store down he said you had a million
dollars worth of instruments you do okay
I won't hand for that you keep the other
hand and go make another store is this
mr. living room guy mr. Lieberman and I
went to jail and all health when I went
away all hell broke loose walked around
like his Nicky Scarfo Julian any oh my
god oh my god what what what happened I
said what happened now you hear these
stories and they have no damn no proof
they never did anything in any casino
town that weren't allowed in Vegas
before I became with as Hanley the head
of the because of the culture you know
all them people when we got off the
plane woman one time me and Mike Maronna
the lieutenant cop capsules they were
there to pick us up you're in coming
here well I never did you're not coming
here unless you want to see the desert
they said they were known the Berber
guys in the desert the cops when they
were real bad that's what I know so we
all got together we ended up after that
I could go anywhere well as Hanley and
we could do what we wanted to do in
Atlantic City
we all started to make money on the
insurance imagine under 30,000 members
paying you insurance foot health
insurance or any other insurance you had
don't you have to give if you're gonna
make over the last thirty thousand if
you're gonna make ten thousand don't you
have to give me a few pennies because
I'm the guy that sent him over to see
you and it works that way that's how you
were making that money at that time in
Atlantic City
yeah is that also the time with the five
hundred thousand quaaludes and ten kilos
of cocaine or now oh no they set me up I
have done you sell that and my cousin
Raymond and Charlie on set me up Raymond
would soon I'm gonna lose my house and
it's me like the jerk hope that I am I
said you're not lying I did not him and
Charlie Alan set me up and flattened him
in Florida and they took me away and I
said my wife and children all by
themselves but we we did okay so you had
nothing to do with the the quaaludes and
and cocaine Oh Donna I was squirting out
then what money what money so so let's
fast-forward so now that's forward you
it's an you end up doing time you're in
jail I think with Joey Merlino and you
guys are together he knows that you're
have some experience in the past
obviously with the Angelo Bruno and he
his father you know he comes from a
family as a certain lineage how does how
did those conversations take place
between you and morally no didn't you
becoming a boss most probably very
simple mm-hmm Joe Mannino owed everybody
in the city of filling up there a lot of
money nobody trusted him now he has a
crew Michael Chang who got killed and
Russia he had a crew and he had
something that I didn't have there's
nobody around but then and he told me
everything that they had in this and
that he was gonna do this good you're
gonna do that okay I'm gonna back you
I said where's in New York anybody goes
to their Joe Morelli no I'm gonna kill
him
I didn't say I'm going to hurt them I'm
good I'm gonna kill them it's the only
way to say to people that know that
and they know where it comes from and
this is what he is but Joe Mannino ended
up being a punk date I went to trial
found guilty and then I said okay I'm
gonna go there I win I said they send me
an envelope with massive deals and words
in it every cent my wife an envelope or
to live on you know what they got for
one year I waited a year nothing I said
I'm now on faces another one I called
the FBI want to talk to you and that's
how I become a witness at the end of my
career look at him and when I got in
there I said and these punks and the
judge I'll use the words I want to use
he gave me as much as they got 13 years
and he gave me 13 years and say nice and
I did it every [ __ ] day those Punk's
Chameli you - and how about one day they
killed poor Sal be I know his whole
story money does nothing he knows
nothing - dumbest man in the world he's
a liar you listen to him you'll build a
house Warren he's a liar he's a boy he
owes everybody everybody that had
anything to do with him I see him I oh
my god he is a punk
I called them punks every game because
they're punks that's why he gave me
thirteen give them 30 [ __ ] I did time
before just 16 got another 13 is 39
years and bad joints how'd you become a
boss though because that's where the
controversy comes in much moisture
controversy so you're in jail you're in
prison with Joey you guys are thinking
about coming out there's a strategy to
create a war because it's an opportunity
for you to take over you might enjoy it
and then you know you know it's very
very very very very simple yeah I became
a bush cause I said I'm the boss
I came on anybody that doesn't like it I
don't hide I Drive around to go to track
you could come I was always and I was on
the parole and I had a pistol on me
cause them come you know how many people
send up nobody excuse me for raising my
voice is just I remember what my wife
had to do so you came out of normal
swore you when you became a boss there
was no I was sworn in already but I even
forgot to tell when the only swimming in
that I ever had was me Angelo Bruno and
caller gave me the book all three of us
cut our fingers
color so that's gotta be a prison we
want it that way you belong to me and
you belong Vinge now that's why they
sent me to Chicago nobody could touch me
that's why and you want to listen to
people of you I don't know what you're
doing but kind of enjoy so unit I've
never met George he's a punk he's a liar
and he's afraid of people I saved his
life they wonder kill him from New York
I said I'll put my life up for him let
ask him then what he's done to people
the money goes to people his mother he
resisted why even talk about it
you guys both got out in 2011 all right
did you stay at the same place or know
where you and Joey should work change
placing prison know who was at a
different place than you he could stay
with me
as those that I brought up beat the [ __ ]
outta me
that punk you don't know how to fight
that's what he is
I'm telling you what they are they keyed
on it but they did everything you hurt
everybody
he owes everybody now he's walking the
streets the boss he he met himself the
boys he's a boy
nobody nobody looks at him he can't get
nobody him unless he were like this when
they were
friends they couldn't come near salvie
testa they couldn't come near him true
man a true man do you still keep in
contact with anything mop at all
no no one why should I you don't they
just take him know if I want to I can go
to anywhere and I'll be welcome the guys
from New York were all in Lewisburg they
loved me because I was true attend I
didn't lie to him going back to talking
about Frank Sheeran and we're talking
about this like Sharon's a liar he's a
pathetic
have you seen Irishman there's no I
didn't see it you know the story you
already know it's not a true story it's
no truly even the people that made it to
now save it they made a movie with a lie
three or mental and and took that money
on their woulda be ashamed himself
Pacino they who are the other guys
they're rolled I'm old but I'm not old
I'm old your age what's send out my age
because they came to nothing
what is what I mean they came to nothing
I don't know what that means they can't
do nothing they don't have this they
can't kill me they're not capable what
am I going to tell you I'm trying to
make it look good
they're going to yeah my god last story
here before we go through a speed round
what happened with Sonny Liston with
Cassius Clay night oh you would still
what's the story with I'm gonna taste
very simple Sonny Liston was managed by
blinky Palermo you know blinking Palermo
watch see you don't even know that I
gotta help you if I wasn't here I'm
really giving a story okay
blinky Palermo on Frankie Carbone from
New York Rams a boxing game you have
done this thing blinky Palermo has Sonny
Liston he used to train in Philadelphia
for that fight but Cassius Clay
what happened Cassius Clay was
she opens up at 11 the one on the dog
they went to ten to one and stood that
way
blinky told our friend the gym to listen
you gotta take your time for this one
you using too much heroin because
blinker would have killed him blinky was
waiting 112 pounds he would have killed
it he said what am I supposed to kill
you you're like a son to me I had to
watch how much Herrmann you you shoot in
you that's what he was doing but when he
was training for bind he never took it
and the man you seen in that one picture
when me Frankie which was Hoffman when
he used to get out of line they used to
let Frankie go in and spar with him
Frankie used to be a fighter
thank you still going near him what he
used to do to him Frankie's a big guy
yeah you couldn't if you had a bat
you'd be a loser with Frankie as big and
strong as he was it's quiet and listen
to me all the time
that's why when he called me Hoffman on
the phone I gotta say I gotta say was
something else what happened was
listening listening killed themselves
they don't say somebody he owed heed he
he went down and in the second fight he
went down he's six round he don't want
to come out of the Sun that's another
one they won money every boss and
underboss one fortunes with that first
fight and the second point that cleans
up too because they know was a setup and
of course good thing he ain't one dude
he's afraid of them he was fearless a
picture but he was afraid of them
because they would kill him
Frankie karma would chew him up Franky
carbo's the man they killed Bugsy Siegel
in California in LA he killed him they
got a hundred he chose him the man in
Gray's did all the top killing at that
time simple the [ __ ] there's a whole
crew from the Italians who were building
them casino lending the money in in
Vegas think
again and said now I gotta kill him
that's the difference he took the money
he didn't take your money
the boy took the money and put him he
could he was madly in love with a stick
but they killed him that's not the point
the point is they were all made money
and they killed him give him at Meyer
Lansky ever no no I don't wanna leave
because he gave up his friend he gave up
but bucks a sicko
he gave him up yeah he's down there with
a [ __ ] another lies there as far as I'm
concerned you can do he says yes you can
kill them
and they kill them nice nice when you go
to bed at night you get up you say my
god look what happened Jimmy bugs you or
no huh did you meet Bugsy Ben Siegel
Bugsy shake oh yeah no you never met him
no you met any to form for like Costello
lucky or any of those guys without a
prior no they're not your era no okay
got it okay the last thing here we're
gonna do is speed round I'm gonna give
you a name tell me the first thing that
comes to your mind but where do you call
it speed round
Oh could give you names gay guys and so
we're gonna play a kid game it's okay
we're gonna play kid game all right
first name Joey Merlino spin it on the
ground Nicky Scarfo
a demon Sonny Franzese nice man Sammy
Gravano
another demon Sammy Sammy Gravano what
did he do he killed everybody because he
couldn't go to jail that's why I killed
him
you got understand this that sound like
wool I went to jail I did 29 years I
can't kill everybody people up my cousin
Raymond set me up
my aunt dolly was his mother I love my
aunt dolly she treated me more like a
mother than my mother she said when I
come home they threw a little party
Ralphie please she got me don't kill my
Raymond they won't knew me from since I
was a boy don't kill my Raymond he
didn't nobody was in Charlie let's not
talk about let's have another drink her
mother that's the truth my aunt Galia
don't tell my son what was I going to do
I couldn't do that
some things I couldn't do John VZ a
crumb a crumb what were worried about me
say he's a crumb
he never was any they may have been
thrown gangster Randy shot he got his
brother killed Johnny gongs I don't wait
a minute I know of him but I don't know
okay
alright no opinion Steven Mazzoni he was
with me almost every day when I was home
he become eBay Board a week he went bald
what a week he became a gangster he
couldn't be a gangster when all of us
are dead Angelo Bruno a fine man
like I sold whenever later judges a day
is a fine man a fine old man because he
was that's why he's dead but he was a
great boss but a lot of people Phil
testa stinks let me say some bubble test
he made his man go to sea sand on a post
under captain che settled because testa
and him and Sonoma argument then he says
he'll go to he made him go by himself
and that zip John Stanford who he who he
put in business and put him in bed the
working business
construction he stinks why would even be
because they all have a story they don't
have one story like me I don't have a
story I tell you the truth I'll tell you
what happened what we did I killed Joe
mcgrill you know why because he say told
Charlie Allen you go home kill Ralphie
I'll give me the book you'll be the
second when he come in over there cuz
I'm coming home soon and he's dead cuz
he told a few other guys she's trying to
get somebody to bang me while I was on
the street nice man come with will I
tell it's funny I still come for right
let's go let's go shake down the guys
open the new drink come on
I sang them back home in the back you
see the chapter I wrote on that perfect
and then when he pulled up his ice about
map what's going on here I said I'll
tell you what's going on
I put three in the one hole come back of
his head
three Bing Bing Bing hallo heads you
wanted to kill me I made him next one
one word a good man a good nor yeah
Frank's you're a liar pathetic fool a
fool Tommy and Radha I wouldn't trust
him
Joe batters nobody I give him my life
Carlo Gambino I'll give him my life
Cillian Eddie Phil Leonetti I don't even
like him he's got no ranking in my
skinny razor one of the finest men I
have ever met you shaky one of the
finest men I've ever met you ever met
him and he shake your hands and you
usually stand that George Borghese he
said John Marley knows
hackie nothing nothing
Sal testa a fine young gangster tough as
they come
you know it's amazing because obviously
myself the viewers we hear different
stories but at the end of the day I
didn't hear stories you heard from the
week we hear stories you know notice oh
I'm sorry we hear store okay good
then what you should put then you've got
a you gotta be me the editor of people
that you believe then functions put it
out put it out be a fool look at all of
them now what they're doing and with AJ
look what they did nothing in their life
come on but put your first name Patrick
Patrick said a beautiful name that's
what's listen to me
I will never tell you a lie to make you
cuz I know you there's that everything
I'm telling you is the truth and the day
I go home I'm gonna beat it I'm gonna
think of you and anytime you want to
talk to me about any of this let me know
only I can't take trains like that or
that side from what up thrown my cover a
train but a [ __ ] train you're gonna
be desperate I'll get somebody who's
driving me
but I wish you in in good humor and
don't make a lot of money god bless you
you look like what insurance something
you live your life and live don't listen
to people want to come and you don't
know anything about them you know about
your business please do what you have to
do I'll never hold anything against you
well you say I'm crazy well do this
whatever you do I tell you when I tell
the truth I can't get many you say I'm a
liar okay you're not one of them guys
Patrick please thanks for coming out for
the audience so with that being said you
know you heard a lot of different
stories he says he's telling the truth
you know there's a lot of people that
agree disagree there's a lot of
different rumors and stories out there
but this is the book if you haven't read
it at last dawn standing the secret life
of mob boss Roth Natale highest-ranking
member to become a witness if you
haven't read the book yet click on a
link below to watch it Ralph thanks for
coming out you say well do well
appreciate the insurance bases thank you
yeah that's tradition it is a business
different kind of a story right I mean
the whole story with Jimmy Hoffa and
Carlo Gambino asking him to go and do
stuff with John Gotti in Atlantic City
very different kind of a story so if you
watch this interview you probably watch
a lot of the mob interviews that we have
on guy tainment you're like that series
I got two other ones I want you to watch
that's linked to this one of them is
wood Fillion Eddie who is also part of
Philadelphia was a former underboss and
the other one I want you to watch the
Sammy bull Carano because both stories
were mentioned in today's intervene if
you haven't yet subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye
you